joseph moukarzel bonjour merci de nous
avoir rejoint ce matin sur rtl france
alors jean yves le drian en visite
aujourd'hui au liban
qu'attendent les libanais très
concrètement de cette venue
vous avez parfois au liban bien que la
chance qui bouge donc les libanais à
tant de lagence quelques elle essaye de
les sortir de l'impasse
en tous les cas qu'elle essaye de sortir
les citoyens limani de certains dans
laquelle ils sont pris par les
dirigeants actuels
donc la position de la société libanaise
est clair nous sommes prises en otage
page et politiciens qui sont consistants
dans l'autorité contestée aujourd'hui
parlent dans la rue et on attend de la
france qu'elle essaye de deux nouvelles
première étape bien sûr c'est sortir de
la crise économique par le biais d'un
gouvernement
ça fait des mois reste qu'un an que le
gouvernement ne s'est pas fait donc oui
oui est à la tête de ce gouvernement de
réel à la tête du gouvernement il a été
désigné mais on attend toujours qu'il
constitue ce gouvernement et ce en quoi
le pays quitte elle qui est quand
économiquement et ce qui implique un
problème social un problème n 1 du point
de vue sécuritaire est ce que on sait
qui précisément le ministre des affaires
étrangères française va rencontrer
aujourd'hui au liban
écoutez
cette visite n'a pas été confirmée en
valais les détails de la visite n'ont
pas été confirmées c'est la mère folle à
une visite avec on ne sait pas quelles
sont les personnes qu'il va rencontrer
il semble qu'il va rencontrer deux
résidents il semble qu'il va rencontrer
les résidents de la chambre de riz ont
mal qui rencontrerait le premier
ministre désigné saad hariri mais là
c'est pas confirmé l'entourage et sara
lee dit qu'il n'a pas encore été
contacté
maurice de rendez vous donc ce reste
dans le flou total
il ya sûrement des gens de la société
civile que le miss france il a écouté
parce que c'est eux qui vont parler des
revendications en quarantaine des
attentes du peuple libanais justement
quelles sont ses attentes
aujourd'hui vous savez que quand on est
dans l'impasse
on essaye d'en sortir par n'importe quel
moyen les libanais certains demandent de
nouvelles élections législatives ou
changer la donne mais il semble qu'il
serait très compliqué de le faire
actuellement il n'y a pas suffisamment
de de paix de députés qui ont quitté les
lieux
donc qui ont présenté leur démission et
on devra attendre la halle en trois mois
il me semble que ses limites en tous les
cas pour préparer des élections
législatives connecte en face et dont il
pense que c'est possible mais si c'est
un deux trois mois et ça c'est rien de
tout bloquer en attendant le problème
actuellement c'est qu' aucune décision
prise dans un gouvernement pas un
gouvernement démissionnaire
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est fait le
gouvernement
autant que possible qui soit indépendant
des sociétés politique actuelle et pour
le relancer la discussion avec
la famille essayer d'arriver à assainir
un peu quelque peu l'économie
plus de la moitié du peuple libanais on
parle de même 60 % du papier banner est
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
aujourd'hui on peut s'attendre au pire
dans une situation pareille alors fin
avril paris annonçait des sanctions à
l'encontre de personnalités impliquées
dans le blocage politique en cours ou
alors impliqué dans la corruption
ils ne peuvent plus entrer sur le
territoire français aujourd'hui comment
est-ce que ces mesures elles sont
perçues par les libanais ce qu'elle
serve à quelque chose finalement selon
vous écoutez je les vis sur votre
antenne il ya un plusieurs mois la
france a essayé la carotte
ça n'a pas marché donc aujourd'hui il
faut grandir les sanctions c'est le seul
moyen de faire bouger ces politiciens
vous savez je l'aimais est le phare
libanais visant l'otage
je comprends que le monde
l'international où les capitales du
monde d'aujourd'hui ne va pas intervenir
dans un pays souverain
mais quelque part comme l'a dit monsieur
le drian dans y'a rien ou presque
il y à une assistance à pays en danger à
un peuple en danger est là c'est un
phénomène très gras le monde doit bouger
doit faire quelque chose à dire et on
n'arrive plus à rien faire même si à des
manifestations ces manifestations
tournent au drame
parce que les partis politiques ont des
milices qui elles font tourner en drame
toutes sortes d'interventions dans la
rue donc c'est vraiment un homme qui vit
en rodage qui commence à avoir un qui
commence à voir les problèmes de santé
nos médecins sont enfin de quitter le
pays en masse le pays tel qu'on le
connaît commence à changer la donne
donc avant d'arriver au pij il faut
pousser ces politiciens véreux disons le
à quitter les lieux ou en tout cas à
faire ou bien ou arranger les choses le
plus tôt possible
nous arrivons famine à la fin de
de capitaux qui aide les gens à survivre
donc à partir de famille il ya peut-être
une famine qui va commencer à
s'installer
l'agent des deux présidents dans les
blocs est bloquée même cet argent a été
utilisé pour faire des relais des à
subventionner des denrées alimentaires
qui sont qui fuit en syrie qui a
également des logiques de dans les
subventionner la cire in l'électricité
il a presque plus des visites et c'est
vraiment un pays qui va à la dérive
il faut faire quelque chose je pense que
le ministre le drian est là pour essayer
le rouge et les choses et c'est vraiment
indispensable pour tout le pays reprenne
un petit souffle
merci film en oxygène merci beaucoup
joseph moukarzel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je le rappelle vous
êtes député suppliant des français de
l'étranger est également directeur du
journal satirique at dabur vous étiez en
direct de beyrouth